we begin with a deadly stabbing spree
that brought a wave of violence to
multiple communities in Southern
California officers arrested the suspect
outside a 7-eleven store in Santa Anita
Santa Ana excuse me he is accused in a
series of attacks over two hours that
killed four people and wounded two
others a rampage hits seven locations in
about a five mile radius police call the
attacks random and hate-filled mark
Strassmann is outside that 7-eleven
about 30 miles southeast of Los Angeles
mark what more do we know about the
alleged killer
well good morning police are still
piecing it all together and have not
released the suspects name but this is
the 7-eleven where they arrested him and
put a stop to this lethal rampage inside
here is where the fourth and final
victim was killed random attacks that
police described as pure evil for people
needlessly lost their lives from this
savage suspect police say the killing
spree began when the 33 year old suspect
burglarized an apartment in his own
complex Wednesday afternoon he allegedly
then drove a silver Mercedes and robbed
a nearby bakery its owner did not want
to be seen on camera
he showed me a gun we saw this guy
taking all my register like all the to
the registers I happen after that
robbery the suspect allegedly returned
to the apartment he burglarized and
killed two men by stabbing them
repeatedly within the next two hours
police say he robbed a check-cashing
store and an insurance business where he
stabbed a female employee repeatedly
she's expected to survive just three
minutes later police say the suspect
stopped at a Chevron gas station he
stabbed a man pumping gas that victim
also survived he stabbed a guy he
stabbed them he said them right here and
he could like shank them right through
his nose later the suspect allegedly
drove to a Subway sandwich shop where
police say he killed a customer before
entering the 7-eleven across the street
and there they say he disarmed and
fatally stabbed a security guard by the
time he left the 7-eleven armed with
knives in a handgun police officers were
waiting one of the weapons was visible
in the parking lot it's pure evil when
this happens and we don't see this
happen every day this is one of those
things you see one time in a career the
suspect like all of his victims is
Latino but he had no known connection to
any of them
and police say his only apparent motive
was robbery hate and homicide Dana it
was horrific but it's over an absolutely
chilling mark thank you very much